good morning everyone that's the most
energy I'm gonna have that just hurt me
to set it go to work do you know it's
wild it's a three to four hour workout
most people just do a one-hour yeah I
felt like I did a four-hour SoulCycle
class and if you don't know what we're
referring to we're talking about the
Taylor Swift concert last night
we might be here physically but mentally
we are still at MetLife Stadium my soul
is in Section 501 literally being
checking onto the car this morning am I
like what are we doing like we're gonna
charge on destiny I wish we had the
presence to know that today was not
gonna happen but it's happening I just
wanna let you guys know we always
promise a really great show I can't make
that promise
no promises it'll probably be great just
because we can't help but serve up some
greatness but I have like a canker sore
on my cheek I think literally from just
like screaming and like biting down on
my cheek and like I'm just having so
many issues like I don't know and
they're obviously all Taylor related of
course
honestly we look pretty good because
we're both wearing white and black oh
damn this is my sweatshirt that I bought
at the merch store last night I washed
it after I wore it last night and you
wouldn't know if I didn't because it was
filled with my makeup sweating off it's
right here
literally like I was sweat like sweating
here too like I was drenched it was a
workout humid first of all it was a
workout just the physicality of it all
it was so humid it was also raining I
wore a sweatshirt the whole time like I
was drenched when we got in the car on
the way home we're all starting to smell
something we're like what's it smell
that's one thing go shoes off and it's
like we're just like it was just I think
we just smelled like a locker like a
men's locker and like when we got I got
to the conch she went on at 8:50 I got
to the after parking like I finally set
foot in the stadium probably at like
7:45 and all I had to do was like get a
t-shirt get chicken fingers and pee and
that took me like about 45 minutes we
left early because he had such a large
to-do list yeah get merch get drinks get
food take pictures
find our seats pee but so with my
chicken fingers I didn't get any drinks
because I really did not want to have to
pee during the concert to wake you right
before and then I hadn't drink in like
four hours excuse me and then by the
time we got into the car I was harsh
because I've been like screaming dancing
like
throw it was so driving my saliva tasted
like concrete do you know what I mean
like it was so thick unfortunately I do
know what you mean and then we finally
went to a gas station that was like
literally heaven it was the best gas
station I've ever been to
oh my god I wanted to buy so much stuff
I almost bought a large Turkey Hill Diet
green tea for my brows but I just didn't
have the strength to carry it but let's
talk about the concert I was
unfortunately not present for Charli XCX
or when I was chewing on my Aaron's come
in look away I was playing and I was
like hearing it and I was like oh she
definitely was up singing because I was
literally listening to iTunes I was like
see yeah I saw her on the screen well I
was here my Aaron's in the stadium as
well phoning it in where a Jets jersey
that's sweet I guess does she do that at
all the stadium no but she wore of the
second night a giant's Jersey and then
the night before a Jets jersey he could
say totally also it wasn't which player
anyone good marks and she had her name
on it she should thank Mark Sanchez why
because they're both cute because
they're both Latin no but dude no
totally she is like I just like I know
too much about the behind the scenes of
the total Charli XCX and Camila Kibeho
in the blind and I was like that they
just don't stop doing cocaine and like
and you could tell because they both
have a ton of energy
you know ya know they're just both the
two of them it's just such a disparity
between them and Taylor who was like
straight as an arrow like business
business businesses when they came on to
seeing shake it off with her it's like
these two backup dancers like brightly
no no no and what we were saying in the
car last night is that like from a
business standpoint and like a strategic
standpoint like it does make sense that
Camila is her open our heart a l'heure
are really good friends
Camila's um audience is very similar
terror I'm sure there's a lot of overlap
and Taylor's never gonna give that
platform to someone that's not like in
her inner circle that yes that isn't
gonna backstab and that isn't a threat
like right so I get it like I really do
but the Charli XCX of it all is making
shows how seriously did he go stir Z in
Philly
um crying oh man that is not funny
you're only supposed to do that like in
your hometown like right or like oh
we're performing at this one football
stadium exert off of us does she not
have like our own budget does she not
have allegiances that is so weird that's
crazy
um but Charli xcx's presence was so
bizarre and so unnecessary it's like
she's like kind of like a like dirty do
you know what I mean like I don't get
like she's Leon gee I don't get like the
clean Taylor Swift like no cursing vibe
from her like I get like the VMA like
it's scrap a [ __ ] vibe yeah I don't
want to go to school I just want to
break the rules right and I just get
like British badass you know like she
think she's stupid so I think from a
branding perspective like it really
makes no sense I don't see why there has
to be two openers like I think if it was
just Taylor and Camilla it would've been
fine I think it's nice that they have
two openers because people do get there
at four o'clock and if they're just
better for even longer it's nice that
she makes it a little bit more of a
festival yeah I just like don't I don't
agree with the selection at all when it
comes to Charli XCX no and what's sad is
like Charli XCX has been out here
working in these streets for a very long
time now and like physically came out
like five years ago this is as big as
she's gonna get you know it's I don't
think it's going up from here no and the
fact that she even got this gig is like
a miracle like she's so undeserving you
know I agree I get like I couldn't get
over it a million girls would kill for
this job when I got out of the car let's
she was playing fancy so obviously like
it was over and I was like just so
relieved to not I've I like even have to
see her on screen and then her and
Camille I come out for shake it off on
the B stage and it was just like go away
I was honestly so appreciative because
that was a stage for this for me right
and you know you guys can have them I
took a seat no totally so let's talk
about like the show this yourself was
amazing like she's just the greatest
showman she is a supremely talented
person I feel like she might love that
movie because it's also totally the
story of a girl who loses her show yes I
feel like she might really relate to
them because it's just musically
wonderful what I really liked was it
wasn't like a lot of synergy between the
music the lyrics would take or that
outfits like the the videos were so well
put together like there was really like
a cohesiveness in the branding of like
snakes reputation like it all made sense
you know and I feel like I could really
guess what song she was coming on next
like based on the videos or being sound
like the beat she would applaud yeah
based on the video like getaway car but
here's what's confusing to me like it
was an amazing show and she had
everything pyrotechnics different stages
props this costume wardrobe everything
and it's like I don't know why it was so
good compared to any other show that has
all of those things do you know what I
mean well I think just like us we like
to love her music so like I mean as it
as a show like production-wise
like it is the greatest show like the
fireworks in the fire like I felt a fire
on my face we were saying like you and
the fire went off we could feel it it
felt so good even though we were hot and
sweaty it's just nice having new
sensations yeah other than rain Oh
totally and like just like even if
you're not a teller so I found like
people who like brought their husbands
like you can't deny that it's an
incredible show like it's just amazing
to watch like the dancers it's like
there's just so many elements to it but
then as a Taylor Swift fan she like she
gives you what you want you know yeah
and she gives us as close to answer
since we're ever gonna get yes to like
her headspace hmm and what was going on
during the storyline for her totally so
I felt very much satisfied but now them
le'me axiom mm-hmm between this and 1989
so what are the biggest like regrets of
my life is not going to the red biggest
your guided tour and and there's no gbg4
it when there is a 1989 one and I really
feel like she's gonna do a reputation
one so let me just get that out there
now I'm afraid to say what I'm gonna
gonna say but I really think he's just
saying
I think in 1989 was a better show let me
tell you why I think the music from
reputation was way better but I think
that the show was better for 1989 and
let me tell you why I think it's really
like amazing what Taylor does like
between the main stage being an ex and
she hits all four corners of the ex
between the two stages in the back and
then that carousel that like lifts her
around everyone can get a good picture
like everyone gets a good of you no
matter what your point is see that's not
everyone and it's like she really does
care about like her fans being able to
like have a premium experience no matter
how much they paid which is admirable
but like as someone who cares a lot I
like and honestly I think I had the best
possible view for the whole show where
you please with your seats you give me
three choice of course but like even the
best seat in the house can only get you
60% of the show do you know I mean and
while I appreciate her being so generous
with her fans like I just feel like if
you pay more you should have a better
seat I know that's like bad to say but
technically you got 60% of her vagine in
your face and they
10% yes I agree but like there was like
a decent part of the show that I just
like wasn't a part of no I feel that and
I definitely needs a break and I'm not
glad I was shaken off Charli XCX
threatened the other girl but in 1989 it
was the form of a tea so like this was
the main stage and then the tea was like
a runway where she would walk and give
the people on the floor who spent a lot
of money like even better access yeah so
I thought that was perfect
and I really liked musically what Taylor
did with 1989 cuz I wasn't crazy about a
lot of the songs but she's saying them
so differently on tour than the way they
sound like on iTunes like when she sing
out of the woods which is a song I
wasn't in love with on stage it was like
totally remastered and it was so good
and that's just like proof that she
writes these lyrics and then like just
whatever she wanted them they could be a
hundred different songs and it's the
same as when she like mashes up two
songs it's like she puts her lyrics to
the beat of another one of her songs and
a Tom works yeah so I just think I was
drawn more to 1989 because it was more
the vibe was more like colorful
happiness celebration where his
reputation was like snakes which is so
cool it's just not my personal aesthetic
I feel that when we were in the car and
the way we were listening to just some
of the greatest hits and yeah
real estate estate of grace which is my
personal all-time favorite Taylor Swift
song me too and I was saying like back
in the red in 1989 nice like her music
was like pump up happy pop cheery like
she was like cats and like it was so
cute and now her music is like a luxury
like strong and it's still really good
but it's a totally different riving you
don't have that feeling of like yes like
yeah we're like holy yeah and that's why
um like the messaging and like the decor
goes along with that vibe except I think
right now I would I feel like I like
reputation as an album better than 19
and I just because 9 I've listened to
every song of 1989 because we had two
years of no new music but listen to them
backwards forwards soon so I'm really
sick of it but I think in five years
when I look back on her catalogue of
music I'm gonna think that reputation is
this her worst album oh really I
actually think that reputation is a
better album than 1989 just 1989 was a
show more designed for me okay they were
both incredibly comparable and then a
billion and one dollars okay all the
same it's all the same but what do you
think is her best album red red a
hundred percent
close second to speak
no totally and uh I can't fearless no I
know his Stephen leicht top know Taylor
Swift like it's just it's a Sophie's
Choice
it's a Sophie's Choice and I just feel
like the further you get away from an
album the more you appreciate it
obviously but I really think red is and
not only was red the best album like
Taylor Swift in the red era was the best
Taylor Swift cuz it was before the
tipping point where she like she was
just like with that Kennedy and like
yeah and she was so talented and like so
famous but not to the point where people
hated her just for being alive whereas
like now she like farts and people
literally hate her I agree which brings
us to our first story right Oh might as
well say that in the moment I thought 99
was the greatest album of all time it's
just in with time passing I've listened
to it way too much I need a break yeah
and I'm but it's cuz we had those two
years where we had nothing yeah you're
grasping at straws
so our first story is a Taylor Swift
story we have a video to accompany it
before we play the video
let's preface what's going on here so
Taylor Swift has been doing the
northeast part of her tour like in the
past two weeks so she's been at her home
in New York City which is in Tribeca
everyone knows where she lives and she
goes to a rehearsal at one o'clock and
then she so she leaves her apartment and
gets into a car and drives to the
stadium and people know where she lives
they wait outside they know that she's
coming out like 1 o'clock so people just
New Yorkers paparazzi random people stay
outside her house and wait for her to
come out and then she comes out walks
from the curb what walks from her her
door to the car it can't be more than 20
feet and paparazzi ever on screen takes
pictures videos well wha and a bunch of
the videos have come out of her walking
these like 10 steps which like seemingly
is not a big deal but there's been a ton
of backlash about it and it was a really
heated debate in our morning to us our
Facebook group which I thought raised a
lot of really interesting points and I
just thought would be a good I could
jump in landing off whatever it's
springboarding off springboard yeah ok
great let's play the video and then
we'll talk dive in ready yep go
you
big day dream look in your eye and I got
that red lip
you
we never go out to the place taylor
swift's okay colleagues are great for
people with bad voices yes
okay the video played she walks out she
is just straight faced walks
look straight ahead of her not to her
right now to her left and what I saw a
lot of the backlash was that like people
waited outside for so long like how
could she not smile or at least wave
like just indulge these people who have
been waiting for hours for you and I
personally feel like a very strong way
about it and I just was reading these
different comments in in the group and I
think a bunch of really interesting
points were raised the first one that
was raised was that do you think that a
video like this would have sparked like
a conversation if Taylor Swift was a man
um probably but there's no man really
who like elicits this much Craig made
election every styles but people don't
even know where Harry Styles lives I
think what speaks to her level of
celebrity that people care this much and
I don't think it's because she's a woman
there's very few men that like have what
she has in terms of a fan base totally
but do you think they would have just
been commenting on like how hot he looks
or the fact that he like doesn't smile
do you know what I mean um I don't know
I've yet to see a video right guys and I
feel like when I looked at this video
all I saw it was like oh my god her legs
look amazing
what's the outfit she looks great yeah
like so personally I can't relate to
people who think like that why doesn't
she smile because I don't think like
that there's a million reasons in this
world not to smile right and so I was
just reading the comments and basically
what the comments were saying people are
just like you know when you're at that
level of Fame like you you owe
everything to your fans how could you
not even indulge them for just a second
and then I thought about it and I kept
thinking about and I was like well this
is her house it's not like she's leaving
some restaurant like this or home she's
neighbors like I'm sure they can't be
too happy with the fact that there's 50
people outside probably more like a
hundred people outside their home every
day and I feel like the people who like
wait outside are not really like her
fans do you know any mean they're just
like random New Yorkers I was like I
guess of both I think it's random New
Yorkers who like want to get a picture
an autograph and sell it on eBay but
also fans who like you know have been
staking out her house she's in town
they're coming to town because she's in
town yes but like I follow a lot of
Taylor Smith fan accounts and they like
respect the [ __ ] out of her privacy and
like when Taylor Swift was on vacation
with Joe Alban and like pictures of them
on the beach got leaked like none of her
fans would post it because they're like
it's such an evasion of privacy and they
were like yelling at other people in
comments who would post them like they
care so much I feel like
real fans wouldn't wait wait outside her
house because they know it's that's like
a huge Emile if in New York like imagine
if you were in the suburbs and they were
just like 60 people outside your home
like 10 feet from like where your family
sleeps like it's so different because
you live in New York but the wool should
be the same I agree and like the second
she waves at them or like takes a selfie
or signs an autograph then more people
will start writing and I don't think
she's trying to encourage that I think
she wants to walk to her car she's not
trying to like make it a moment she
doesn't need to wait for the paparazzi
like right they have ruined her life
right um and also those people aren't
paying to be there like if you're at a
concert and you see her and she's a
[ __ ] like that would like you're paying
to be there and that's her job but right
here standing on the street it's your
free will like yeah you don't deserve
anything no and like waiting outside
someone's home it's like such innovation
of privacy that like just her smiling or
waving like just means that she like
would encourage this you know what I
mean okay so I just want to read some of
the comments because people have really
differing opinions and I do too so
someone just wrote a hold on I wanted to
see it man or woman she should have at
least smiled or waved to the fan
screaming her name there the reason she
has everything I just want to say the
reason she has everything guess is
because her friends but it's also
because she's like an incredibly
talented person like she's not like a
nobody like I think there are certainly
people in this world who don't have a
ton of talent and like I really owe it
to just like their Instagram followers
I'm like okay no I'm like I can't do
that but like there's so much more to
Taylor Swift than her fans but also her
fans are everything and she appreciates
them so much at the reputation room
which by the way there was no reputation
room last night so like really upsetting
because if there was we would have
gotten in because we were great ham no
one was going in at least in my section
no maybe they were really together I was
Avenger Asami she would have been like a
mu to the way I could see her but it was
too early in the show the reputation
room is free so like most artists will
charge like crazy amounts for me angry
tickets and will really only be
available to people with like access
like some music executives daughter like
the reputation was completely phrase
she's in like she's only done like ten
shows she's already met over 1500 fans
and she hosts like secret listening
sessions for her like true fans not like
that she knows from tumblr in her house
like she there's no shortage of like
things that she does for her fans so
like I just can't I can't with this
argument of like she's her fans right
here are some of the what you deserve
them okay from
Anita she doesn't know anyone anything
but she loves her fans and was aware of
them being there most artists artists
would have acknowledged them with a wait
well she did turn to one side and smile
away but even if she hadn't done that
like I just wouldn't encourage this like
level of danda totally and like I know
that celebrities live in the public eye
but like everyone I don't care how
famous you are they deserve even the
smallest amount of privacy in like this
whole like like mindset that like our
generation has of like celebrities being
completely open books and they're not
entitled to any privacy like no there
definitely have to be open about a lot
of stuff but like everyone deserves even
the smallest bit of privacy and that
starts with your house like Taylor Swift
has had so many break-ins literally some
man was caught like sleeping in her bed
in this exact apartment like I don't
know I just I'm not here for like I
totally understand her not encouraging
this I mean I totally agree Taylor Lin
thank you for this if she would have
waved or something people would have
been hating in a different way everyone
would call her thirsty or something like
yes like that time she's to only walk
out of her house and she got photographs
every single day walking out of her
house and then it was like she was
putting on her own right Fashion Show
and everyone was like oh she's so
calculated no it's really critical
culated back then like I feel like ever
since this whole reputation thing with
Kim like really shook her whole life to
the core like she spent 22 years
building like this empire off of what
she what she puts out there not what
people know about her what she wants
people to know and then this Kim thing
like totally took that down and now
she's like rebirth as like this
empathetic more like human person but I
just think that like I can't get over
how much I disagree with people on this
no I I totally agree and like who cares
that much like yeah the girl do what she
wants like she's still a human being
yeah maybe she's having a bad day and
you know what she doesn't feel like
smiling right who gives a [ __ ] I just
think like yes every celebrity is an
open book and they don't have the right
to privacy but I think the one thing
that should be private is their house
like that's literally the only thing
they ask for right and like and she
expects that don't expect a wave right
and then like people get mad at her for
being too open about her songs are so
personal like about her boyfriends and
stuff like make up your mind people
literally like now that I'm damned of
you doing your damage you know so all
you can do is exactly what you want you
because
either way you're gonna get [ __ ] yes
well make yourself happy yeah and I just
I don't think that there should be
different rules like if you live in a
city versus if you live like look in the
suburbs you don't I mean well I guess in
the suburbs it's easier because you
would have a gaming we got in your car
right before you leave the gate right
and by the way here's the thing ready
Taylor Swift can go anywhere she wants
without being seen I mean she took a
break for two years and nobody saw her
like that's why when she was recently
snapped outside Lady Gaga's recording
studio walking into where Miley was last
week and like everyone freaked out she
wanted us to know about that like if she
wanted to go somewhere and not be seen
she could she owns like uh two floors in
that building and she has a garage built
in she could just drive out so almost
like her not doing that and just like
taking pictures and everyone is giving
you something yeah she could be she
could get anywhere she wants it up being
seen remember there was that the area
they choose being snuck out of her
apartment in like a species drunk she
was she how do you know because it was
real how do you know when did we get
confirmation I don't know it just was I
don't know if it was but she they could
never saw her leaving in her apartment
but a man used to walk out with a big
trunk right like that holds like music
equipment and they said that she's being
snuck out through the trunk but like if
she does have a secret garage like why
does she need to go out in the trunk
like it's the new garages new I just
read about it oh okay so I thought she
was building like a town house with a
garage she's doing something she just
bought like the longer sort house is
even less secure for her she she's
staying in a building yeah for sure
okay look no but you're for sure because
I just feel like overall thoughts on the
show and her as a human being a plus and
I also want to say that I'm sorry to her
for everything that she went through and
that I definitely was not there for her
she needed us most well this is we were
like like we were living for the drama
by the way I'm not seeing anything
because like I don't really feel like I
should have to choose between like my
two queens like I stand them both of the
two people in the entire worlds like I
think Kim and Taylor are like most
important to me like I would like spend
a ton of money on the Taylor concert I
don't spend a ton of money on like a
meet grieveth Kim like I don't really
feel like I should have to choose and
I'm not like I'm not taking sides I'm
very much in the middle I really hope
that they can work it out and even if
they can't we understand but I actually
feel like eventually they will me too I
really really do and I feel like Kim
doesn't like to have bees no and
I feel like it was a type like first she
sour then she's sweet like yeah she'll
like you know [ __ ] all over something
and then like be like okay I'm sorry I
just been through a lot like Taylor's
been to realize yeah I just don't know
if Taylor what like ever like has so
much venting heart for cam she buries
hatches but she keeps maps of where she
puts them that is the most telling lyric
like yeah she'll bury the hatchet but
she'll never forget what you do and I
don't think she'll ever forget and I
don't know how she could like she just
did a whole album a whole stadium tour
about what Kim did to her right so this
is the craziest thing like say what you
want but like she took the absolute
worst thing that happened to her like to
us it doesn't seem like a big deal it's
just a video but to her it's like years
and years of like building an image
completely shattered and she did lose a
lot of fans because of it because it was
really weird what she did I say what you
want like she [ __ ] lied like sorry so
it's actually incredible what she turned
this into she is like literally breaking
so many records she's doing less shows
than she did in 1989 but she's serving
like double the amount of people like
she will not perform in Addison Square
Garden which is like the most
prestigious arena in the world she's not
performing at one single arena she's the
first woman will show 1889 she didn't
perform a she no not a messin Square
Garden but at some arenas some okay this
is stadium only like the only person I
know that perform such a stadiums it's
like Bruce Springsteen I'm like Coldplay
and Beyonce yeah but like it's just it's
mind-blowing what she turned like
something sour into what it's actually
inspiring it is inspiring but I feel
like we gotta move on soon because yes
it's like now it's all we talk about I
feel like sometimes summer tees do
things and like you actually forget like
it's been two years now like we could
have forgotten Rose always reminding us
yeah so yeah I'm ready - I'm ready I'm
ready next album but I'm very proud of
her me too
this show was amazing I had the great
highly recommend highly recommend which
I didn't go on a Sunday night's unbroken
today - but worth every my throat really
hurts my just my legs at my hip I my
joints hurt yeah okay great it's joints
ready
okay this short this second story is
really [ __ ] wild
and just makes you think really hard
Kathy Griffin says she fought with Ellen
DeGeneres about Joan Rivers the comedian
Kathy Griffin who was told she would
never work again just played a sold out
show at the Dolby theatre Kathy Griffin
who was dropped by a representation
fired by CNN and squatty potty alike I'm
you reprobate honestly that's like the
dream Brad I would squat like could you
imagine us that would be so cool and
have you ever used the squatty potty yes
it's epic I'm gonna get one it's pretty
good
I'm put under a media blackout after she
took part in a photo shoot that saw her
holding a Donald Trump mask dripping in
ketchup implying the President had to be
been beheaded has been on a laugh your
head off tour world work tour honestly
that's a great name for a bachelorette
off your head off world tour to prove
that just because they tried to put her
out to pasture doesn't mean she would
move she said at her Los Angeles stop
Thursday it's not all jokes tonight she
said I'm also spilling piping hot tea
self-proclaimed to be known for being a
star [ __ ] who tells dick jokes her
three-hour set performed in the now
infamous dress from that Tyler Shields
photo she hours said that's crazy didn't
skimp on the usual brand of raucous
Frank storytelling that helped her earn
a grammy for best comedy album in 2014
and hit the bestseller list twice
despite the fact that it was an la crowd
and you probably all know her griffin
revealed she got into a fight with Ellen
DeGeneres after Joan Rivers died one of
the things that really hurt Joan and we
talked about it at our last meal
together was that Ellen always shunned
her and Ellen thought she was vulgar and
not funny and Griffin said noting that
DeGeneres thinks she's also too vulgar
but when Rivers died Griffin wanted to
reach out I just called her and I just
said look woman to woman comic to comic
I think you need to let go of your
hatred for Joan Rivers she's passed away
just do a [ __ ] tribute totally
Griffin said but according to Griffin
DeGeneres wasn't having it and responded
that there's a difference between mean
and funny and Rivers was mean that
[ __ ] set me off Griffin admitted so
we had a fight in which I used
inflammatory words like look you [ __ ]
untalented hack you know when you're
fighting with someone you can't you can
kind of get to that yes kind of laugh
and at a point yeah not that day a
couple of days later Griffin said she
texted generous to say that she couldn't
stop thinking about the fight they had
it was so dynasty that I demanded to be
Alexis as long as you're Chris Bell she
recalled writing I think we should do a
scene in the pool I think there should
be big hats and that [ __ ] didn't even
respond but that was a good idea Oh BAM
so I've recently like had this like
revolution when it comes to Ellen a
Renaissance Revelation revelation
I've read
songs if you will so I like used to San
Ellen like I think she did yes like I
think she her show is so funny and she
really does like such good work on her
show like her in Walmart and her in
Cheerios or like always gay always
giving money to such a worthy causes
like schools that need money like can i
watch the show and I just like feel good
no it's good talent great performers
like Noah Ritter like I just think her
show is a good place like it's a happy
place like she really is an LGBTQ icon
I completely Rae but you know with your
stuff in the past couple months I've
like kind of turned on her because I'd
heard rumors that she's like a huge
[ __ ] like if your honor if you work for
a show or if you're a guest like you
literally can't look her in the eyes and
in Korean told us that she was like the
scariest woman alive and I do think
everyone earns their right to be as much
of a diva as they want but like I don't
know when your job is like all a lot
about like philanthropy like how can you
be such a two-faced [ __ ] like no and
like you're saying that Joan Rivers was
mean and not funny like yours would mean
to your face and at least Joan was mean
and funny like you're mean and jury's
out on funny
according know you're eating cars
episode they're like funny and then
you're mean like to someone else like
and then guess last night is a flying I
know and I'm gonna kill it when it comes
to me it's like I'm sort of Breaking Bad
well yeah I never saw wait but then last
night I watched her episode of comedians
in cars with Jerry Seinfeld and I came
up with two theories one she didn't
speak the whole time and it's like well
that makes sense because she's like now
for her shows been on the air but for
fifteen years she's used to people
writing things for her and like she
delivers it very funny but like she
isn't it to come up with an original
thought like literally in 20 years and
she was being so mean to Jerry like
making fun of him like from the sniper
from the side you know like she was like
did you just turn the turn signal on
like yeah that's what you do when you
drive lights what you do it's the law no
like I was just getting such bad vibes
I'm her and she was like so not funny
and I'm like wow maybe she isn't funny
like everything's just literally like a
team of writers she has her own company
like I wouldn't be funny if I'd people
running for me to write so it's just
like I'm kind of turned on her I turn on
her - this is definitely the final nail
like you do not [ __ ] with Joan like Joan
is the end-all be-all she is like the
female comic I kind of
panting of anyone in comedy that I like
love more and stand more than Joker that
like achieved as much as Joe and it was
funnier than Joe yeah and especially
like in her death now she's iconic
forever no matter what you thought of
her even after she died Ellen came to
bury the hatchet like you can [ __ ]
scram that is like that is the epitome
of like holding a grudge dead and you
can't get over it that would be like if
God forbid something happened to Kim
yeah and Taylor like was still surprised
[ __ ] right but like Kim technically did
something to Taylor Joe never did
anything to Ellen Jones existence
bothered Ellen like that's [ __ ]
that's such [ __ ] Jones everything
and I feel great like this like this
there's been a series of Ellen things
that I used to really enjoy her show to
you like you should watch all the
highlights on YouTube very good stuff
Noah Ritter is literally my son and I
just forgot again first to him yeah and
now I've moved on
yeah and where is Noah Ritter he's fine
he works still for Ellen to ellentube
yeah yeah yeah he's friends with Mason
Ramsey they should be also I saw her
interview with Mason Rams he was like
extremely condescending not completely
and like she was like not protecting him
she was like making fun of him and like
that was the big event it's like
wholesome dreams oh you want $15,000 to
go to college or the Opry like it was
just not like she was not in tune with
what's necessary no not at all
and I saw something so funny that when
Joan died someone paired together all
the terrible things like Jonah said
about like some celebrities and then the
celebrities who tweeted at her like she
caught she wrote something about Rihanna
looking like a Nazi once and then
Rihanna was like happy birthday Jalen
like such as no I mean rest in peace
don't Joan Rivers really tweeted like
about how sad it wasn't like the whole
world knew like it's just a joke like
don't take it too seriously but Ellen a
comic didn't know that like if I knew
what did you'll never even say about
Ellen nothing she just thought she was
too vulgar and definitely I think there
were comics were too vulgar but I don't
hate them no listen it's not Joan I
don't think John was too vulgar I think
like Sarah Silverman is to longer like
every when we saw Michelle wolf
literally every word out of her mouth
was dick or [ __ ] like that's vulgar
yeah
Jonas was mean but mean is a brand of
humor I agree I also like find me Mean
Joe and quote that isn't true
right it's not mean if it's true
that's like the up no anyone else then
it's me honestly we've never needed a
Joan more than we do in this climb my
dad and while I'm like I'm happy she's
at peace I really need her know I need
her and like she was always putting [ __ ]
into perspective and she was like oh
she's just right about everything
I just can't know it's so sad it's
racist and that [ __ ] doctor can rot
in hell I've never been like so
profoundly affected by the death of a
celebrity as I was with Joan Rivers
scene and I don't think about like dead
celebrities ever but I think about Joan
like all the time what would Joan say
about this yeah and like I watch her
stand-up like I really like feel her her
absence no sane oh that documentary and
like she didn't get the respect that she
doesn't know in her lifetime and like we
suck collectively as a people my boy
justice for Joan you guys Joan invented
who are you wearing
yeah she just invented everything I
[ __ ] love her so much
okay are you ready for this next story
yes it's actually a very exciting story
and it's a little bit of travel news end
of the airport nightmare new scanners
may finally mean end of liquid ban which
has frustrated passengers for 12 years
CC er this is me why user says
everything so funny because you just
reminded me of something when I was
brushing my teeth that I wanted to tell
the story oh well you say this first new
scanners will be trials at Heathrow
Airport which could mean the end of
strict rules on carrying liquid bottles
on planes computed tomography technology
could allow x-ray scanners to produce a
3d image of the contents of passengers
luggage and detect any explosives the
ban on liquid bottles which requires
passengers to put small quantities of
toiletries in a plastic bag which is
very [ __ ] sad came into force after a
terror plot was foiled in 2007 saying
don't look at your phone so some people
in the comments are like saying
celebrities whose deaths they really
like are not over like really think
about all the time and someone wrote
Robert Williams oh really so but I
thought I said something wrong like this
yeah sorry sorry so we might be able to
bring liquids on plane soon which is so
exciting like you could you don't have
to buy a five-dollar water in the
airport right and it's not gonna be
Dasani right you could bring some
alcohol right oh that's right you could
bring your beauty products yes you don't
have to be like a little mouse yeah
is setting spray rosewater but then you
know it so crazy that I just learned
like because I had a rose water that the
the Mario Badescu small size it's like
one fluid ounce that's why I mined up I
bought a little cuddly one which is
amazing but mine was like basically
finished there was like the tiniest bit
left this still wouldn't let me bring it
even though there was a probably half a
fluid ounce in there just because the
bottle isn't so crazy so [ __ ] up I
thought this through and it's [ __ ]
okay but wait so I wanted to tell you my
story because I was in the Denver
Airport which by the way I've had the
honor since going on tour to see some of
the country's worst airports and I've
decided that it's Denver even though
there's crazy conspiracy conspiracy
theories about the Denver Airport have
you heard yeah oh that's the carpet
what oh sorry what's the carpet there's
an airport carpet thing but what they
say is everyone's like you know about
the Denver Airport I'm like what like
you have to take a train it's so
annoying like no matter what terminal
you're at you have to take a train it's
so stupid I hate that
so there's apparently there's like a
crazy underground area of the Denver
Airport which they say the Illuminati
meets at okay whatever Denver right wait
ready you're gonna say in Denver - this
- they also say it's in said they have
such a you know robust underground that
the Queen which comes to America flies
to Denver and then goes underground look
who makes this up I don't know if
someone's like have you heard the
conspiracy theories like that whoa
that's okay yeah carpet the airport I
just spewed a little Airport carpet so
apparently at Portland International
Airport the carpet features geometric
shapes on a teal background representing
the intersection of the north and south
runways seen by Eric traffic controllers
I don't know but it's like it went viral
this carpet okay okay so in the Denver
Airport which is just [ __ ] terrible
it's so big that like the clothes even
if you have the best possible scenario
with your date you still have to take
two escalators at a train like I hate
those trains like gonna guess if you
later it's fine if you're in I just want
to be dramatic like okay so I was going
through security which by the way it was
10:30 they were acting like it was 4:00
in the morning like they closed every
single gate security the city that
sleeps and they kept having arrows - the
one that was open so I get there no TSA
PreCheck which is so annoying whatever
so I get in line and they take my bag
and it's like my purse it was like
nothing in there and
when I finally got my things checked
checked out it was my keychain they
didn't know what like this really set it
off the keychain we didn't know what it
was like it's a keychain so stupid but I
literally had to wait 20 minutes to get
this woman to check my bag because the
guy in front of me it was a woman and
her kid the kid's bag got checked and
the kids like fluoride spongebob
flavored toothpaste got taken away and
he like was not stop crying about the
stupid toothpaste away so this TSA agent
took it upon herself like teach the kid
about terrorists like in the ten seconds
like she was like if I let this she was
trying to explain and read like hey she
did a bad job and because she scared the
[ __ ] out of the skin good she was like
if I let this odd and this toothpaste
kill someone kid is like three years old
and this chick paste kill someone that
would be very bad the kids like why
would my Jews kill someone it was so
spongebob right she was being like so
like vulgar I'm surprised the mom like
didn't grab the kid the kid was so young
he was just like crying about his new
face it was so stupid and like all the
while he was done like I needed my bag
and I had to wait for her for storytime
to be over it was so sick they don't
have the time to do airport security but
they have yeah I'm to tell so the bad
guy takes your toothpaste and kill
someone Wow Wow but soon soon as you can
bring his toothpaste on the plane you
know now I've gotten acclimated to not
bringing no and like not having
hairspray when I travel right okay since
when is hairspray liquid
well I need dry shampoo it was like but
now they took my whole thing away
because I brought a full-size dry
shampoo that yeah I guess in its air
show nope it's this cat makes an aerosol
spray but in the bottle its liquid
[ __ ] [ __ ] I mean that's just
this is just the world we live in
it's ocean I'm not defending it but it's
I'm really excited for it to be over
like where all the beauty queens out
there these machines where like they
scan you remember when they were like so
crazy controvert so people are like they
can see you naked like on the cover of
the New York Times it's like a huge deal
like they don't even seem naked they
just get like a scam no but if I'm sure
they can see
but it's like sorry but like everyone
was so worried like all the moms like I
don't feel safe you know yeah well you
can't go in there if you're pregnant I
believe so the radiation that is crazy
we're being rated it upon them you don't
even know it whatever it's gonna like
it's gonna come out for sure that like
one of those machines like was related
to someone's infertility it's like not
good to have that radiation that's what
I'm saying
but now sometimes they let you just walk
through yeah simple they totally racial
profile like if they think you're like
cute they'll let you through or if they
think you're young because anytime they
ask me how old I am at the airport it's
because they think I look younger than
13 because that's how old you have to be
to go through one of those machines no
like literally I was online it was so
long so they look like 10 people through
and they did not let me through do I
look like suspicious I don't know I feel
like you're always turning trouble
that's your trouble me they did the
right thing
okay our next story is very sad for all
these Ritz cracker fans there's been a
rich recall certain snacks recalled due
to salmonella concerns reports Fox 8
Cleveland salmonella is for me this is
crackers the maker of Ritz products
Mondelez global announced a voluntary
recall of Emily man delays to or delays
bendlin know it's that from Seinfeld on
delays let's go whip it up in bond
please announced a voluntary recall of
some of its Ritz cracker sandwiches and
Ritz bitz products according to a press
release the affected products contain a
white high power which the supplier has
recalled you to the potential presence
of Salmonella the retail is limited
exclusively to the products below a
whole laundry list of Ritz cracker know
what this sounds like they're just being
safe like the odds that a fashion that
there are Salmonella is low but like I
appreciate them taking the right
precautions yeah there have not been any
complaints of the illness at this point
according to the company who asked
consumers to throw out any of these
products can't get a refund that's so
funny cuz I aid Ritz crackers over the
weekend now you're not feeling so well I
got Ritz crackers and Sun Chips and I
opened the Sun Chips and they were like
so stale and I was like oh then i open
the Ritz crackers and they were also
sell and I look it's just this weird a
guy in Jennifer was selling snacks that
expired in April is crazy no they're
already gone it's it's so crazy when you
find an expired
chip because like how long has it been
there for it must have the old branding
stone also the Denver chips the bags was
like you know what on a plane on your
burger packing bag of chips and it's
like huge yeah because the altitude is
so high in Denver like my chips were
huge cuz you were sky-high I don't know
where you sky-high in Colorado I did not
get sky-high in Colorado but at my show
in Denver which was incredibly live I
sang Scott high in Colorado every like I
was singing tequila and like everyone
was with me but then when that line came
like everyone saying it was like really
epic that is really epic yeah I'm sure
that line has brought a lot of joy to
the yeah to the towns well apparently
dispensaries are on like every corner
but I couldn't find one I just wanted to
go in and take a picture I don't smoke
pot but I literally the people were like
you haven't seen one I'm like no they
have like green plus signs so if you had
bought some you know marriage I could I
brought it back ya know they would have
stopped you yeah maybe they thought you
had Mary J and that's why they put you
in that yeah in my keychain whatever um
also I have to say something about my
Denver show because like it was so crazy
first of all there was a toasty pregame
that like I wanted to go to but I'd
soundcheck and it looked so fun like
literally 60 people oh yeah they were
like literally I basically just like
stood on the stage and saying like 60
toasters came and they looked so cute
and they like all my best friends this
girl came out to me agreed she was like
I'd literally moved to Denver two days
ago and now I'd like a hundred friends
it was so cute
but after my show right before the meet
and greet this security guard came up to
me she was like this really sweet woman
and she was like I'm really sorry I'm
like what she's like literally I've
worked here for ten years we host mostly
like punk rock and rock and roll shows
and it never had to throw as many people
out as I did from your show I'm like
what she's like literally people are
going to the bar and buying bottles and
then bring them back to their seats
that's crazy no no and like I knew
everyone was like pretty drunk but and
when I was in st. Louis I was like wow
this is the drunkest crowd ever
literally at the meeting greet some girl
fell over and knocked over the like the
backdrop I was like okay some other
robosub wasted she told me that I sucked
like it was so crazy
everyone was so drunk and I mean I can't
get any drunker than this and then I
went to Denver it was in sane that's
wild I'm sure there are a lot of people
who don't remember the mean green like
they were so black I'm like they weren't
even talking English what do you think
it is just your presence I think that
they all pregame together right right I
think they expect it to be more
difficult to get drinks at the bug now I
gotta show them like it's impossible to
get a drink but comedy clubs like it's
time then
and it's like a restaurants like there's
a waitress for every table it's just a
lot easier to get drinks than they think
and it's so crazy how drunk everyone
gets that's insane
speaking of toastie meetups the there
was a toast to Deanna in Indiana and it
was [ __ ] why awared was hosted because I
think it was New Testaments apartment
and it was like mad nights no it was
still nice it was like a loss yeah and
there it was kind of a dude and I
believe that Indiana was like a large
toaster watering hole and that like
there are the tosya snow stirs yeah and
the ciaz toaster toaster named Utah
Stephens hosted an Indiana toasters like
just like des rager at his house and
like literally everyone was blackout
drunk they were putting pictures and
videos and the group of them all just
like rolling around drunk it was so
funny it looked like it looks like a
caught like a frat party
yeah and we're like really fun it looks
really fun and they was giving me like
just so much excitement for Kantos yeah
that literally save also like a little
bit of a pit because I don't think I
realize like how much the toasters drink
like I drink a lot but like the end is
so drought no but it's like individually
toasters drink a lot and then when they
all come together as guys it's like
something of y'all have in common
you know Kantos could be an incredible
[ __ ] show no I think it will be but it
has to be measured because like I really
want to accomplish some somebody we can
treat during the day I want to play the
weekend I feel like beer and wine during
the day okay that's nice
yeah like you're with lunch I like
buzzed a beer in the burger oh yeah
that's nice yeah got that in the wine
you know it's gonna be so let's okay
this and final story want to be
socialite our girl Anna may have built
the fire festival Foster for number one
fraudster of the year she wanting to who
though page six we have a winner in the
scammer Olympics after page six learned
that socialite grifter anis Arkin
managed to bilk months of free
accommodations in the Soho loft out of a
fellow alleged heavyweight con artist
Fri festival organizer Billy mcFarland
in May 2017 it was revealed that Sorkin
has had posed as a German air is called
an Adele V to allegedly trick banks
businesses and friends into giving her
hundreds of thousands of dollars in cash
and goods but we hear that New York's
most beloved swindlers went head to head
back in 2013 when Sorkin who managed to
stay at high-end hotels such as 11
Howard four months before being
discovered
moved into the Wooster Street
headquarters of McFarland's dubious
credit-card company
Magne sis for four months Anna knew
people on Billy's team explains an
insider she just asked to stay for a few
days then she wouldn't leave so she
conned the Connor the Connor yeah
she like conned Billy mcFarland into
what I to letting her stay at his
headquarters Wow magnesia switch
McFarland's once no toilet notoriously
said is Latin for absolutely nothing
produce black cards linked to members
regular credit card accounts and also
through bashes at the Soho loft she hung
out and went to party says the source
she was there just sitting there all the
time our source says mcFarland who is
awaiting sentencing scheduled for
thursday after pleading guilty to fraud
for duping investors into his failed
2017 music festival is actually a polite
and non-confrontational person who was
only able to hint that he wanted Sark
aim to leave he hinted the staff hinted
explains a source
she had blunt Yaga bags and clothes
everywhere the company wound up moving
into a townhouse that's the only way
they got her out she had been there for
four months oh my god the student
becomes the master Wow honestly these
two are a power couple imagine what they
could they could take over the world who
do you think is a bigger scammer
I think her because honestly like his
scam was really foiled very quickly and
she went on with this charade for years
you know she's definitely better at it
and she had more longevity but he
effected away more people that's you're
like really she's so from banks who like
they have enough money right he stole
from like nice people who just wanted to
have a good time like he's actually
corrupt I totally agree but he really
did expose like a level of thirst and
you know incident everyone in everyone
just like people who wanted to go to a
festival on the beach Instagram no even
if it was like a success like I never
would have but that is the last place I
would ever go right like you don't go to
that festival if you're not just
Thursday thirsty and like the fact that
you would I have been to Coachella is
like a cetana shame cuz we're like anti
Coachella like we really are but we went
to work and you know what like premium
content just never sleeps workers got to
work whether it's Coachella or whether
it's here oh my god so funny I got like
the most nasty D I'm after my Denver
show about a girl who said like I'm not
funny and like I should just quit like
it was so me and she was there and she
was like insulting me left and right
she's like I'm just giving you honest
feedback like she really thought she was
helping me and like in her Instagram bio
I was like a reference of something we
said it's like serving up premium
content like we say that like it was
just like
hilarious you notice mind turn a couple
spoons yes I just said the spoon emoji
that's amazing yeah I got such great
gifts at the meet and greet and I got a
couple things for you and a letter
I love me yeah wait I got so much food
that I ate on the plane what's this one
girl like apparently she'd been DMing
Olivia for like months she put together
like the most premium care package for
me like for the plane a box of Reese's
cereal remember I was just saying Skippy
smooth not chunky a spoon that says in
great to eat my ass like it was the most
metal straws I forgot uh hold on I want
to say her name because like she really
deserves it and idea I was like yes so
munching and I actually have decided
that I'm gonna I mean my sure my
household is gonna become a metal straw
ideally Oh Bridget Bridget I just want
to give her a shout out you and she came
that's a my pajamas and a toasty kimono
oh my goodness I just ordered a toasty
kimono
I ordered a toasty romper and like it
was so flattering oh no a toasty not
come on a toasty robe so I can get ready
being toasty oh that's cute yeah I got
it from Katherine Dennis's Instagram
story which is so amazing segue wait
wait no hold on one second did you see
Kacey Musgraves toasty ass outfit in
Honolulu first of all she looked like
believed oh yeah he's got me so skinny
and like she's she's era no pre who's
the same she does yep she doesn't open
use the same trainer that was in city
strong I don't think she's associated
with city strong which is Kaitlyn saying
and she does Kelsey's legs and carries
Underwood's wags and legs and now he
does the women of countries like yes and
like the only women it's the only shot I
have it ever having nice slices Erin
sorry so I just want to say toasty I
mean Casey was very a toasty romper and
like a light pink kimono which looked
amazing and toasty
sorry what about southern Germany's oh
my god so much drama over the weekend
with southern charm and then I read a
comment in the toasters that made me
rethink everything okay why don't you
take it from the beginning
well someone in the toasters group sent
us just posted this random picture they
found of Ashley and at first I didn't
think it was Ashley because it looked
nothing like her the girl had like huge
boobs and like Boston they're seen it
look like her and then the more elected
I'm like oh it's totally her and
everyone chameleon everyone went insane
on the comment so I posted it on our
instrument was like wow she looks so
different and I checked Ashley obviously
she booked us within moments of the
picture going up but she's smart cuz now
it doesn't show up in her tag photos and
I just let me tag her anymore but
just so annoying what else and then she
was in the Facebook group oh right oh my
god so then I think this actually might
have even happened before we do like
live threads on our Facebook group of
girls like who are watching things live
they all like watched together and
comment together and apparently they
were like these two fake facebook
accounts I'd like didn't have photos and
like how to fake names and like we're
brand new Facebook accounts that were
like in the comments like defending
Ashley and like being mean to everyone
like it was obviously Ashley it was like
Holly Chili's all her way in I know
we're so strict about horses especially
about like joined Facebook recently yeah
that's like the big is is you just join
Facebook and you're too toaster but
you're like a teacher and so you never
had facebook I'm sorry it's such a red
flag I'm not gonna happen yeah so I
don't know how the hell she got in and
it's so crazy and then like Shep texted
me he was like where did you find that
picture stop yeah and I was like
literally like one of the coasters like
on the round and what'd he say he was
like he was just like she's so like
different looking like everyone that I'd
like that picture
he's so telling of so many things so
many thing is it's like back then she
was like a whatever she was bottle
service girl big titties and now she's
like trying to be a woman of Charleston
she's a nurse she's a chameleon what's
like a movie where make that movie
imposter that show imposters about where
the girl is different in every scene
yeah that's her she looked yeah but then
I read something on um someone commented
something that like made me feel kind of
bad and like this was like I was like
kind of piling on to like what everyone
was saying about her but then they were
like honestly like I'm really worried
about her like she's so like her mental
health is obviously like in such fragile
state and like with like literally the
entire world like packing it on like
just like ganging up on her like she
like is such in such a fragile state
like they're like afraid that she might
do something like because she's in such
like a fragile mental state and then I
was like I kind of felt bad and I was
like I don't want to be like a just
another person and I know you're like
reality TV is sake but she's definitely
like a bad person and like his evil and
like said terrible things to Kathryn and
I just I just I hate her still but like
I don't think I want to like publicly
like be mean to her anymore do you know
any mean like something about I
understand but I feel like that's such a
cop-out when people are like oh my god
she's in a fragile mental state like
Thomas is man
relating her brainwashing her like first
of all she moved to Charleston on her
own accord knowing full well what she
sees you to know if you watch the show
she will not let him go he liked it she
had it's not him like wrangling her and
keeping her like he's like you're free
to go and she like refuses to let go
she's like on it also she's I know what
it was when Kathryn and Thomas met like
Kathryn was a child
truely read he took advantage actually
is 30 plus she is a practicing nurse she
knows all about mental health like she
knows all about health and she is making
all of these choices on her own so just
like to say oh you know she's like in a
fragile mental state and she's on the
show and people are being mean to her
like I just think isn't really it's a
cop-out like you see you know we can
sign up for with reality TV everybody
gets the brunt of it at one point or
another no one ever said this about
Kathryn oh you guys we should stop being
mean it's it's a pile-on that's true and
Kathryn was never as horrible as Ashley
no totally also I don't know if I've
said this yet but she does have
something on Thomas she said this like a
bunch of times did he say what's in the
sex tape
I don't think so cuz this is a family
show so you don't want to say it cuz I
dunno just go ahead Thomas with two
lesbians and two dildos
Jo deals us oh I only heard dildo you
know what movie I watched this weekend
that it's just so underrated what Bruno
well Sasha Baron Cohen the sequel to
Borat oh and he's a little bored when it
came out like it was just no Borat but
watching him this weekend first of all
it's just so applicable to the times and
it's so funny we were laughing outlet
Sacha Baron Cohen is really like a
unique talent I haven't watched his new
show yet me neither and Kareem was on
the last night and I really want to see
it I saw clip and it was so funny and
she was like a really good sport about
it totally people like complaining about
it like Sarah Palin like stop like it's
a joke okay like Craig's do like me in
on the joke like Rihanna's just has the
best attitude about the 7 it's like it
she seems like she's in on the joke ya
know she was like a really good sport
about it like I just like people who can
laugh at themselves do you an email a
totally take themselves so seriously
that relax relax don't do it when you go
to [ __ ] I'm so tired I'm so tired I'm I
usually I start to show tired and by the
and I'm like let's ya know it sounds
like I'm dead like it oho I'm getting an
official like a medical lymphatic
massage today just because I have like
still a bum for my surgery and sadducees
head it'll really help it go away if you
get like a real lymphatic massage I'm so
I'm going to this girl named she's it's
like a Russian name in Netanya or
something I'm really I'll let you know
no it's like Netanya that's amazing
you know I'm really excited just on my
face I feel like I'm gonna fall asleep
hey cuz I'm tired and B I love getting
my face I'm literally gonna fall asleep
on the car on the way home like I'm so
tired guys this has been a great joy oh
wait people wanna know what you thought
about shutter island' is it shelter or
shutter shutter okay you guys had so
many thing that can wake me up is my
thoughts on shutter island' it took
Jackie four days to watch it took me two
days watching movie because I was
worried that I wasn't able to sleep I
was home alone it was dark and then I
realized after I finished it the next
day in the daytime that I actually could
have finished in at night because the
ending was way more palatable than what
you thought was going on
however there's so many different
theories as to what could have happened
and we've discussed this a little bit
and I'm so glad I watch this movie I'm
so glad I didn't let you spoil it for me
because I never watch movies that aren't
like rom-com kissing literally lurid
clueless for the 85th totally so it was
just nice to get out of my comfort zone
a little bit agreed and really use my
brain and you try they love using my
brain you told me there was a giant
choice so like I had so much time in
between I watching the first half and
the second half that all I thought about
was the twist right and it still didn't
figure it out it's almost better to know
that there's not a twist coming no but I
didn't think I just thought the choice
was gonna be like oh Mark Ruffalo is
working for the island right like not
that the whole movie right is oh sorry
spoiler not that the whole movie is from
the perspective of the crazy man but
wait sorry I just I'm on are chosen so
Graham and you know the skincare brand
Ahava you're just on Instagram right now
no I just saw a message and I'm like I
need I need a Sun notification and I was
like I need to tap it you know that
Israeli yes of course they tell you us
an Instagram story someone who works I
was watching the toast she definitely
had to put it on her personal Instagram
account she's gonna get fired but still
no it says love Ahava you guys the Dead
Sea Mass it's the best [ __ ] everything
awesome stuff yeah this salt for the
bath she felt but bath salts you should
know about it says premium content
always the morning shows it's definitely
like a social media manager who's about
to get fired no she's definitely not
because like I feel like it's good for
the brand to have it you should get
there in two
the millenials yeah anyway so we were
talking about theories shutter island'
and there's three there's three things
that we can still the end use up three
possibilities yeah and I said I had to
watch like one of these explainers just
to make sure I was understanding
everything right because it took me so
long to even like believe the doctor cuz
I was like you're gonna try and tell me
that Leo's crazy like we've been
watching him this whole time right and
we know you're corrupt right and you're
like doing SS I thought it was you
walking through the front door you're
the one doing lobotomies and pieces out
of the brain right but then once the
names were in anagram I was like okay
okay maybe you have some legit it's when
he was around I was like shucks right
and like he is patient 67 and he wrote
that note to himself
okay so right someone's missing right so
the one theory is that you know the
doctor is right he's crazy they let them
they let him live out this fantasy
because I thought he would become clear
and he did but it was just like really
nice that they all like role played this
whole island seems like a really nice
mental institution that they like do
drama class like that yes the second
theory it seems like an extreme lengths
to go for a crazy person right the and
so and that by the end it's unclear at
this if he is lucid and he chooses to
lobotomize himself because he can't live
with the guilt of what he's done or he
really thinks he's a detective again and
everything was for nothing or three
which is what I think he really is a
detective and the institution has made
him the crazy I don't think it's that I
do oh wow you're a real conspiracy
someone they show the lighthouse at the
end it's like sorry boom you know oh I
really think I need to be watching again
cuz you know like now my new show that
like I've obviously forgotten about cuz
I've been watching movies since high
school you have and Martin Scorsese said
like this movie's gonna make double the
amount of money because you have to see
it twice I mean I have seen it twice but
a long time ago like now I need to watch
you back from IVs always a mindset of
some kinds of and I don't all make sense
also Andrew Reynes or whatever his name
is is clearly a toaster with his toasty
tie yes so like that was just a nice
touch Martin Scorsese thank you no Leo
did a great job that scene when he comes
back to his house on the lake and the
wife is and all the kids are floating in
the oh my god that is the craziest scene
but like here's my thing that I was
debating so he kills his wife because
his wife killed the children but I don't
think that makes him the most violent
prisoner in the last
and it made me think cuz the doctor said
something to the effect of you are the
most violent prisoner you come into the
most violent crimes um so I feel like he
got he went into trauma mode after that
and then did some terrible things on the
force and there's even worse things that
he did that they didn't have the heart
to tell him because that was all he
could handle was knowing about his wife
and children what can he have done like
I don't know killed some people that
weren't bad like he was a cop so maybe
he turned into a bad cop hmm right I
just got that vibe that there was much
worse things as he did if the worst
thing that he did was his kill his wife
after she drowned their children like he
doesn't deserve a lobotomy totally
justified neither right it's actually
technically not justified because he was
armed she was on armed like she wasn't
dangerous he's heard of who's to call
the cops but like sure she deserved to
die right and also he couldn't forgive
himself for letting he knew that his
wife wasn't well and he left the kids
with her yeah and she tried to burn that
in their apartment and it's like I'm
just confused yeah but that was just I
do try to burn down an apartment and you
just burn down one how big of a pit did
you have one like that you turn the kids
over and like the kids are in the lake
and like you they were just dead no I
was getting like the Holocaust pits like
I wasn't expecting Holocaust movie when
ya know it was like a weird and like
when the liberation of Dachau and like
there were all these bodies and then
like of course their eyes open just like
kill me now yeah totally that's when I
had to turn it off middle of the night
it's like a dark dark movie no it's very
dark definitely watch it during the
daytime well now everyone here is either
seen in or it's been spoiled for them
sorry
in an effort to not know we haven't we
gave everyone enough time to watch it
totally but the reason why you initially
wanted to spoil it we were talking about
Leo getting an Oscar he eventually got
it for the revenant but he should have
gotten it for anything else he was in
know and shutter island' like how like
the fact that we are so unsure of what
he actually was just proves how good of
an actor he is like he was playing all
sides like the fact that he went for
revenant where he just like had sex with
a bear where as opposed to like Shutter
Island where he's like the most complex
it's just no or even wolf of Washington
hmm
so in so many movies I thought Django
was amazing like maybe I watched at neck
yeah there's it's really like an
upsetting movie maybe I won't yes
they're just I'm glad he got his Oscar
but like there's so many movies where he
deserved you know Gilbert Grape like
this Gilbert Grape is he you know what I
realized he used me a pin in every movie
he's in panic it's like you know what
yeah I mean Gilbert Grape gave me the
biggest pet not wolf of wallstreet no
that's a fun one
yeah but Shutter Island is Pitt central
like it's just scariest movie no and the
music yeah don't dog and nothing even
happens it's just like they put shutter
island' like it says shutter island'
it's like don't look at right lights
yeah it's so annoying like whoever
scored that movie is like out of control
all right is that it I think that's it I
had one more thing to say about shutter
island' but I can't remember you'll see
you tomorrow with Derek pets oh my god I
think honestly I think I'm gonna step
out for the interview no it's okay
because I have a really good idea what
wearing your wedding dress well I would
say I'm gonna do that but I have
something funny hard to tell you do you
want alone time because no I don't I'm
sitting between you guys like the
tension like nobody it's better that way
cuz like everybody nice so I'm Jackee
I'm married like if you're in the middle
you're the only thing stopping me so
like if I'm next to know I'm gonna bring
a knife to cut the tension please okay
thank you guys so much for tuning and
we'll be back tomorrow like we said with
Derek path I'm here Wednesday I'm here
Thursday I'm not your Friday cuz I'm
heading to Phoenix for my show Friday
night at 10 o'clock so it's gonna be
like even more wasted cuz you know wow
my shows are at 7 and everyone goes out
after and drinks but like my shows at
10:00 you should come I should come I
have to be back on Sunday for Zac Brown
Band a few ducks out I'm coming back
Saturday so it's gonna be late there are
still tickets left stand-up live at 10
o'clock Friday night Carl with no job
calm this is the morning toast the
Millennial morning show basically we go
live Monday through Friday 10:30 a.m.
Eastern Time and we live stream on
Facebook and YouTube and we just talk
about the real issues you know like you
know the Kardashians Taylor Swift
concert like the really important things
that are happening with liquids that are
important to us Millennials so if that's
something that you would be interested
or someone you know would be interested
in make sure to like us on facebook at
the morning toast subscribe to us on
youtube at the morning toast and then if
your commuter if you know watching is
not your thing you're more of a listener
we also convert every day's episode into
a podcast so make sure you subscribe
housed in the podcast or act the money
toast and if you are not an iPhone user
we're also available on soundcloud a
student coming to Spotify I think that's
all I got for you
peace peace
you